you know the family motto is never
complained never explain but it's just a
motto and it doesn't really hold there's
a lot of complaining and a lot of
explaining and private being done in
through leagues through leaks they feel
as though it's better to keep us somehow
as the villains Prince Harry's not
holding back about the royal family as
he prepares to drop his Memoir spare I
think the greatest threat and the
greatest concern certainly for the
Royals is the forthcoming autobiography
I think that concerns them far more this
is the autobiography by Prince Harry and
which is of course caused a lot of
consternation in Royal circles a lot of
concern amongst senior Royal sources and
and Palisades because quite simply they
don't know what to expect the Duke of
Sussex taped two big interviews to
promote the book including a 60-minute
special that one's with Anderson Cooper
and in it Harry explains why he's been
so open about the ins and outs of
stepping away from the firm alongside
his wife Meghan Markle they will feed or
have a conversation with the
correspondent and that correspondent
will literally be spoon fed information
and write the story and then the bottom
of it they will say that they've reached
out to Buckingham Palace for comment but
the whole story is Buckingham Palace
commenting so when we're being told for
the last six years we can't put a
statement out to protect you but you do
it for other members of the family there
becomes a point when
silence his betrayal then there's
Harry's ITV interview with Tom bradby
never needed to be this way the leaking
and the planting I want a family not an
institution they feel as though it's
better to keep us somehow as the villain
yeah but despite ongoing tension with
his brother Prince William and father
King Charles he wants to repair those
relationships they've shown absolutely
no willingness to reconcile I would like
to get my father back I would like to
have my brother back I think everyone
wants to see a repair in the Riff
because it doesn't do anyone any good to
have this rift at the heart of the House
of Windsor here is candid conversations
follow his and Megan's Netflix
docu-series Harry and Megan it was
terrifying to have my brother um Scream
and Shout at me and my father say things
that just simply weren't true and my
grandmother you know quietly sit there
and sort of take it all in I saw us told
E.T that multiple members of the royal
family are angry about what was shown
particularly Prince William and there's
no trust left we're told everyone
remains wary about Harry until his book
comes out concerned about what claims
may come out next so I think there is
just a great sense of mistrust within
the family they just simply feel that
any reconciliation is not on the cards
because they can't they can't trust that
it's not going to end up in a TV show or
in a book
[Music]
thank you